the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello and welcome so last week we
started to think about programming
programming was the first module in this
class and it was important for two
different reasons first we're going to
use programming throughout the term in
the study of all the different things
that we do so it's important that you
learn to program now just so that you
can use that tool more importantly
perhaps we didn't just learn how to
program we focused on how to program in
a fashion that would let us construct
complicated systems out of simpler
systems this is a way that we can manage
complexity this is the only possible way
that we can make complicated systems so
that was the more important intellectual
theme from the first part where we
introduced the our mantra pcap
primitives means of combination
abstraction and identifying patterns
that's the key to this modular approach
to hierarchical kind of design today
what I want to do is start the second
major theme first theme was the design
of complex systems we saw that by
reference to programming today we're
going to start thinking about modeling
and controlling physical systems the
idea here is not so much how you
construct systems but we will get back
to that
the idea is to characterize the systems
that you've constructed and say
something about their metrics as being
positive or negative so what we want to
do is in fact focus on behavior so to
illustrate that I'll start with an
example this is an example that you did
in design lab last week or for some of
you yesterday the idea was to program
the robot so that it could sense the
distance to a wall where
two ways here sort of the view that you
would get from soar and a more schematic
representation showing the position of a
robot the position of a wall the idea is
that you can sense the position to the
wall using the sonars you know where you
would like to be because some user told
you you'd like to be say half a meter
away from the wall and your job was to
move the robot write a program that
moves the robot from where it is to
where where you'd like it to be so
here's the kind of behavior we might
have liked so I'll do that again so we
might have liked that if you started
here you'd have a nice smooth
progression up to where you'd like to be
very graceful ballet type and you just
sort of smoothly glide into the position
that you'd like some of you probably
achieved that behavior and some of you
probably did other things so but that
might be the intended behavior one way
to achieve the intended behavior is to
use what we call a proportional
controller in a proportional controller
you command you make the command be in
some way proportionate to the intended
response so imagine this code which
might establish a class for finding the
wall so the important thing as we solve
for all state machines the important
thing is to define a start state and a
neck getnextvalues routine what this
getnextvalues routine does is it
establishes the desired distance to be a
half a meter it figures out the current
distance to the wall by reading the Sun
ours and then it specifies an action so
the first question is what would you
like F Val to be in order to make a
proportional controller which of those
expressions make sense take 30 seconds
talk to your neighbor figure out some
answer between 1 & 5 I will ask you in
30 seconds to raise your hand with that
number of fingers
so what's the right kind of expression
if we wanted the controller to be
proportionate everybody raise your hand
show me some number of fingers okay the
vast majorities is saying to everybody
likes the idea of current - desired why
is that the right answer
that is right answer why is that the
right answer how do you prove that to
somebody yeah so that method we might
call extreme cases think of the
simplifying cases that give you some
insight into them into the problem so
once one simple case is what if desired
and current were the same you'd better
stop okay that's a simple case so the
simple case says that you better have
one of these whatever the right answer
is it better have the property that when
current equals desired F values zero
otherwise it's not going to work and in
fact using just that one simple case you
can eliminate all the ones except two
there are some other simple cases what
are some other simple cases similar
cases yeah so current we're bigger that
would mean that you were starting out
way over here someplace so if you were
way over there someplace you'd want the
velocity to be positive the forward
velocity should be positive that's how
you would disambiguate the sign right
similarly if the the current were
shorter than desired if you were too
close to the wall you'd like to have a
lot before velocity to be negative okay
so that's the proportional controller
that we'd like so we might fill in our
wall finder class this way and then when
we built it if things went really well
we would get exactly the behavior we
wanted but if things went more naturally
it wouldn't quite work that way and you
might get a different kind of behavior
let's do that again so so here's the
resulting behavior for that simple
controller that I just showed so in some
sense that's not as good behavior and
the way we want to think about behaviors
the way we're going to develop today is
to think about behaviors in terms of
signals plots so the first question is
what plot best represents the behavior
that I saw here so which of those plots
best represents that behavior take 30
seconds talk to your neighbor or figure
out what's they already answer
okay so which behavior best represents
the the Illustrated cartoon that I
showed previously raise your hand show
some number of fingers so that I can see
if you're with it not all correct but
more than 90% correct more than 90%
answer is number two what's good about
number two that's not good about numbers
one three and four roughly the same so
what's showed here is a plot current
distance on the y axis step number on
the x axis and so we can see from here
and the implication of the axes by the
way is zero so the into the implication
of the vertical axis is it intersects
this at zero unless I label it otherwise
and similarly this horizontal line
intersects the vertical at zero unless I
label it otherwise so that's the point
zero zero so the implication here is
that the initial and the final values
are the same as they are here here
they're not what makes two better than
one
just at the curb distance starts out
bigger than it ultimately is so we start
out bigger than the final value the
final value is presumably half a meter
we start out roughly twice that far and
then we see some approach the approach
is not monotonic so the answer is to why
do you think it undershot so on the way
to going from 1 to 1/2 it went through
it transiently went through something
smaller than 1/2 what do you think it
did that yeah time between when it does
one thing and it does something else
when it senses and moves for example so
there could be a time delay in the
system and in fact that's true there is
a time delay so it takes some amount of
time for the sonars to register the
distance then it takes some amount of
time for the computer inside the robot
to register that the sonars told it
something different then it takes some
time from the time the computer commands
the wheels until the robot starts moving
all of those cumulative effects mean
that you have the potential to overshoot
where you're going because there's delay
in the system there's inertia in the
robot all of those reasons can lead to
overshoot and the point of today is to
figure out some way of predicting and
correcting for those kinds of unintended
behaviors so what we will do then is
develop an approach focused on signals
not systems so so far we've been
thinking about how do you build the
system now we're going to think about
behavior we're going to think about
analyzing that behavior and the focus is
going to be on what was the input what
was desired what was the output what was
achieved so we're going to be looking at
those output signals in order to figure
out how good the behavior was
that approach is called the signals and
systems approach the idea is
characterize your system whatever that
system is a physical system a
mathematical system a computational
system whatever it is think about it by
the way it transforms an input signal
into an output signal that's kind of a
bizarre way to think about systems so
let me just illustrate that by way of a
system that you've all seen before okay
here's a simple system right you've all
seen this right anything like 801 make
you know ring any bells
you know okay so that's a simple system
you all know how to solve it there's a
gazillion ways you could solve this
system right Freebody diagrams kinetic
energy potential energy there's a
gazillion ways you could do it you all
know how to do it that's not the point
the point is that we're going to learn a
different way to solve it we're going to
think about the mass and spring system
not like potential energy and kinetic
energy
not like Freebody diagrams we're going
to think about it as transforming an
input signal into an output signal so
the input signal it's kind of arbitrary
what I use IDEs the input the output but
clearly the thing I have control over is
my hand okay so it seems natural to
associate a variable with the position
of my hand that would be acts also seems
natural to associate a variable with the
position of the mass that could be the
output Y that's not unique every time we
try to solve solve a problem we ask
ourselves what's the meaningful input
what's the meaningful output the
meaningful output could have been the
force on the spring okay I'm just sort
of arbitrarily saying for the purpose of
my analysis I'm going to consider the
input to be the position of the hand the
output to be the position of the mass
and I'm going to think about the mass
and spring system as a box that
transforms X into y so rather than
thinking about it in terms of Freebody
diagrams and kinetic energy and
potential energy I'm going to think
there's some input signal X and there's
some output signal Y and what I'd like
to do
is given X calculate y okay bizarre why
would I do that one of the reasons I
want to do that is that it's a very
general way of thinking about behaviors
it works for the mass in spring so some
it works for water tanks what happens if
I have water flowing into a tank that's
leaky well it leaks into another tank
which is leaky and that leaks more
completely different physics probably
wasn't covered in 801 probably is
something you could figure out the point
is that from the signals and systems
point of view I'm going to map this
physics whatever it is into this
structure think about the tank system as
the system that transforms some input
the input is that there's water spurting
for some small interval of time the
output is that there's water coming out
and the idea is that I'm going to
characterize the system whatever it is
as the rule that transforms the input
signal into the output signal here's a
third example I could think of a cell
phone system here again there are very
complicated ways we can think about the
system but I'm going to take the
particularly simple approach called
signals and systems then I'm going to
characterize the phone system by the way
it transforms some input sound into some
output sound and as you can imagine
there's a way of thinking about
performance in terms of that
transformation ideally we would like
this to bear some resemblance to that so
the point then is that we're going to
focus on behaviors and to do so we're
going to think about the signals and
systems approach represent a system
whatever it is by the way it transforms
inputs into outputs one of the reasons
we like the approach is that it's so
general so you can use it for virtually
any kind of a system for which you can
develop a mathematical underpinning
you can use it to analyze electric
resistance mechanical assistant optical
systems acoustic system biological
system financial systems if you're on
the dark side so there's lots there's
lots of different kinds of systems that
are amenable to this kind of approach
also the probe has a nice modularity
having represented a cell phone by a
transformation from sound into
electromagnetic field out as illustrated
by this cartoon depicting sound going in
and having a radio wave to transmit into
a tower then we represent tower to tower
communications some way maybe via an
optical fiber maybe via a satellite then
tower to cell by the same kind of
reverse transformation that we used in
the first one we can piece those all
together we can treat them as modules
because each box takes an input signal
it makes an output signal the method is
oblivious to the underlying physics that
affords a certain amount of power and in
particular we can it's very modular you
can put together modules that represent
very different physical substrates that
allows us to go back to pcap if the
underlying representations for the
different physical substrates are the
same we will be able to and we will over
the next three weeks develop a bunch of
techniques for combining multiple
modules into one that provides the same
kind of abstraction and modularity that
we saw in programming for the last two
weeks so that's the idea what we want to
do is represent a system by the way it
transforms an input signal to an output
signal there are many different kinds of
inputs and outputs but a fundamental
distinction that we are going to have to
make is continuous time and discrete
time this system works in what we will
refer to as continuous time because my
position of my hand is a continuous
function of the continuous variable time
the robots by contrast work with what we
will call discrete time steps it turns
out the math for those two different
approaches are very different and we
will focus entirely in this class on
discrete time because our area of
application is the robot it's not that
continuous is deeper or harder or
anything like that it's just different
so we'll focus on discrete time and the
point of today then is to develop some
representations for signals and systems
of the discrete time nature that will
let us analyze and predict behaviors of
systems like the robot system the first
class of methods for representing such
systems is difference equations
difference equations are a lot like
differential equations except there's no
differentials there's differences
difference equations are the
discrete-time analogue of differential
equations for continuous-time systems
simplest possible example here say I
have an output Y that for reasons that I
that I don't care about I know can be
represented as the difference between
two values of the input X at time N and
X at time n minus 1 that's a way to
represent the behavior of a system a
discrete-time system by using a
difference equation that's in fact
almost a complete description of the
system so let me just explain the way
you would use that it's almost because I
didn't tell you anything about the in
play I'll tell you something about the
input for the purpose of example where
I'll use the simplest possible input
that I can imagine something that we'll
call a delta function
a delta function is a signal
it's a discrete-time signal it has the
value one if the time index is zero and
has the value zero everywhere else it's
in some sense the simplest possible
signal that we could imagine so it's
natural to start there so what I want to
do now is think about if this were a
characterization of the system and if
this were the input to that system
what would the output be that's after
all that was the question that I posed
at the beginning we would like to build
a representation for a system so that we
can predict the output given the input
so how does that work so given the
difference equation all we need to do is
step through it ok it's trivial we call
that analyzing by step by step
so given so given the the difference
equation given the input signal all we
need to do is sequentially go through
the different values of N and think
about the implication of the system on
that input so if I were to use the value
of n being minus 1 this general form of
the difference equation tells me that
the minus 1 value of n for the output is
related by this difference with the
input so Y of minus 1 is X of minus 1
minus X of minus 2 since both of those
are 0 it says that the output at time
minus 1 is 0 trivial right trivial and
similarly we can just iterate through
the solution to the whole signal so Y of
0 is X of 0 minus X of minus 1 X of 0 is
that special one that is 1 so now we get
1 minus 0 which is 1 y of 1 is X of 1
minus X of 0 now the special one is on
the other side of the minus sign so the
answer is minus 1
why of two is X of 2 minus X of 1
they're both zero and in fact all the
answers from now on are going to be zero
so what I just did is a trivial example
of I use a difference equation to
represent a system and I figured out the
output signal from the input signal
that's the method that we call that's
the representation for discrete-time
systems that we refer to as difference
equations difference equations are very
powerful as we will see of all the
representations we look at difference
equations is the most compact
representation but there are features of
other kinds of representations that are
also valuable so the next representation
I want to look at is a block diagram
what I'm trying to show here is a
picture a diagram that represents the
same system that we just analyzed with
difference equations here though I'm
thinking about it as a signal flow path
I'm thinking about what's the Cascade of
operations that you need to do on each
sample in order to get from the input to
the output
so the difference equation said every
value of the output should equal the
corresponding value of the input less
the value before that I represent that
in a block diagram by saying there's a
straight-through path Y of n is equal to
X of n the plus just adds the signals on
these two paths so Y of n is equal to X
of n subtract out because I'm
multiplying by minus 1 delay so I'm
getting the one from before so this
block diagram just is a symbolic
representation of that difference
equation the value of the block diagram
will see several of them but one of them
is focus on signal flow path if you want
to visualize
the transformation from an input output
the block diagram can provide insight
visual insight into what that
transformation is like
so as before if I gave you this
representation rather than the
difference equation you could still step
by step and figure out the way it work
it's still easy there's one new caveat
here we have to start the system in a
state the state that we will usually
talk about is what we will call at rest
at rest just means all the outputs of
all the delays are initially zero so
that specifies the state of the system
at the time the signal is turned on so
the system is at rest which means that
all the delays start out with an output
equal to 0 so at rest means this delay
has an output of 0 well if I tell you
the output is 0 at time 0 for this delay
then it's a simple matter of stepping
through what is the output for each
corresponding implant so if I the
special value of the Delta function is
that it's 1 at the time 0 so at the time
0 there's one coming in that one makes
it through the adder adds to 0 well this
is 0 because it was at rest so the 1
adds to 0 and the output becomes 1
notice that the 1 also goes down this
path and goes through the gain of minus
1 to give me minus 1 but I'm in step 0
so at step 0 the output of the delay is
0 not minus 1 so the output then for
time equals 0 is y equals 1 just like we
saw for the difference equation after
all I'm hypothesizing that those two
systems are the same they better give me
the same answer so then at time at the
next instant as the time index goes from
0 to 1 two things happen the input goes
from 1 to 0 and the delay box gets
updated the delay is now reporting to me
the value that was at its implant so the
output
the delay which had been zero because it
was at rest becomes minus one so then
what happens the one goes to zero the
zero goes to minus one the one adds to
the zero adds to minus one and we get an
answer which is minus one then the input
becomes 0 that 0 comes down here the
minus 1 goes to zero we end up with 0
being added to 0 and the next answer is
0 etc so the idea then is that you can
step through the block diagram
representation just like you would a
difference equation it's just that now
we're thinking about these blocks
characterizing the system rather than
think he goes math that's characterizing
the system why on earth would you do
that what's good and bad what's the
relative merits of difference equations
versus block diagrams take 30 seconds
talk to your neighbor or figure out some
good feature of each
good
I multiply
okay we'll start with the easy one
what's a feature what's a property of
the difference equation that makes it
very good yeah automatically the block
diagram could be solved
maybe not mathematically but kind of
could you refine that a little more
what's what's special about difference
equations that's different from block
diagrams yeah right it's a very simple
expression to say that it's it's by
contrast a bit more complicated to draw
this picture right it's mathematically
concise right it's completely accurate
self-contained concise small it's a very
concise representation of a system so
why would we want to use block diagrams
can anybody think of any good reason for
block diagrams other than Freeman's up
front saying do block I ready for reason
I would hope I don't disagree with that
reason why do I like reclaim videos like
this yeah
it's more physical is there anything
that you can see in this what you can't
see in math yeah that's a really good
point it's kind of isomorphic to the
implementation everybody get that it's
kind of a picture of the way you would
build the system along those lines
there's some bit of information there's
actually more information in this one
than there is in that one it is exactly
one bit more information in the block
diagram what's that bit delay this kind
of delay by the N minus 1 yeah yes the
errors are the big is you can't tell
from the difference equation what's the
input in the output you can tell from
the block diagram what is the input in
the out play by the direction of the
arrows so there's more information in
the block diagram there's another way of
thinking about it and this is kind of a
summary of several comments that came
from the audience the difference
equation is declarative it tells you a
true statement about what the system
will do the block diagram is imperative
it tells you what to do now take the
input put it into an adder take the
input x -1 put it into a delay take the
delay output put it into an adder the
representation where the block diagram
is imperative it tells you what to do so
there's extra info
Meishan but it comes at a cost it's a
more complicated representation it's a
whole picture instead of just an
equation what we like to do and what I'm
going to do now is develop a different
mathematical approach where you get a
different equation that has the same
properties of concision the same
conciseness but also contains all of the
information that was in the block
diagram and the way to do that is to
change our focus and this is the big
abstraction of the day change our focus
from thinking about samples to thinking
about signals stop thinking about X of n
start thinking about the input signal X
this is the same kind of lumping that
was key to abstraction in Python put all
the interesting data together into a
list put all the interesting operations
together into a definition here put all
of the interesting samples together into
one signal so what we want to do is
develop a math by which we can operate
on signals instead of samples so what
I'm going to do is replace the
representation X of n little X of n with
cap X cap X means all of the ends it's
the signal X cap Y means the signal Y
and I'm going to reinterpret all the
boxes this box means take this signal or
the whole thing all n values of it
multiply it sample by sample by -1 flip
the whole signal upside down so I'm
going to reinterpret all of the
operations on the block diagram in terms
of signals rather than samples to do
that I need a representation a
mathematical represent
for the delay box and I'm going to call
that are the right shift operator if you
apply the right shift operator to a
signal axe it takes the whole signal X
and shifts it to the right one
that's all it does so I'm going to say y
equals are applied to act or more
abbreviated are X simply says let Y
represent the signal that is the same as
X except every sample is shifted to the
right the entire signal shifted to the
right that's going to let me represent
this block diagram this way Y the whole
signal Y is the sum of the whole signal
X subtract out are applied to X or even
more concisely calculate Y by applying
to X the operator one minus R so I'm
thinking now of an operator an operator
is not something that works on a number
operations work on numbers operators
operate on signals so I'm thinking about
operator expressions I'm going to try to
formulate the transformation from the
input to the output in terms of
operators the way I take X which is the
input and turn it into Y is to operate
on it with the operator 1 minus R okay
just to see that you're with me
connecting signals and samples assume
that Y is rx which of the following is
also true take 30 seconds talk to your
neighbor figure out some number one
through five
you
okay so which representation works best
one two three four or none of the above
everybody raise your hands tell me some
number okay
virtually 100% correct the answer is two
why is the answer to here's somebody
explain that concisely and then I ask
got wrong of course everybody can
explain it concisely do I have a
volunteer to explain it concisely yes
operator
so you think about it so a good way to
think about this is to think about
simple cases right that's the same thing
I talked about earlier what's a simple
case well what if X let's imagine that X
is simple so let's say that X looks like
that don't sir X is Delta what would
happen what is the signal our X it's the
right shift operator so what's the
signal our XO like shifted to the right
right that's the whole point so the
right shift operator gives you that
signal and we've said that that's why so
is it true that Y of n is X of n for all
n no is it true that Y of n plus 1 is
equal to X of n for all n well is it
true for N equals 0 yeah thank you
so if we did N equals zero right we
would get Y of one which happens to be
one and X of zero which also happens to
be one and if we chose any other end we
would get two zeros so at least for this
simple case it seems to be true and if
you think about building up upon this
simple case you can convince yourself
that number two is always true and in
fact the general rule is going to be
that the left-hand side has to have a
number that's bigger than the right-hand
side which is only true for number two
so the idea then is that by changing our
focus by looking not at samples but
looking instead at signals we can
generate in algebra that looks for all
the world like difference equations
except it knows the direction from the
input to the output so it's more
powerful and in fact this new algebra is
going to obey some very simple
properties which we can see we get a
hint at here if we were to cascade two
systems imagine this system which looks
just like the system we've been looking
at but it's cascaded with a clone the
question is what would be the behavior
of that cascade well according to our
operator representation this y1 signal
is just the 1 minus R operator applied
to X analogously the y2 signal should be
a similar one minus R operator applied
to the y1 signal which gives us a very
concise representation for the Cascade
the point of the slide is that the
operator representation gives us a
representation that is just as compact
as difference equations it has other
features that it can be
manipulated just like difference
equations so if we if we continue with
the same example and try to think of the
transformation on a sample level we
could say that y2 is y1 the
straightforward path the straight path -
y1 delayed but then we could substitute
for y1 of n that y1 of n is X of n this
this path subtract X of n minus 1
similarly collapse and we get a simple
expression now if we think about that
same sequence of operations in operator
notation we get a much simpler
expression throw away the index
arithmetic it's just R so the y2
operator is 1 minus R applied to the y1
signal the y1 signal is 1 minus R
applied to the X signal the total is 1
minus R the operator squared which by
polynomial math is just 1 minus 2 R plus
R squared the same thing we got there
the point is the operator notation is
just as compact as the difference
equation representation and it contains
all the information that's in block
diagrams and it's just as easy to to
manipulate as a polynomial so it's got
lots of features that make it superior
to difference equations the most
important of which is you will be able
to understand all systems that we
represent using the R operator using
polynomial arithmetic something you
learned in high school there's nothing
new here that's what we like
representations that simplify the task
of finding an answer we'll be able to
find the answer to these operator
expressions by treating them as Paulo
so you can get a feeling for the way
that works by looking here the power of
this so the power here is that among
other things you'll be able to use the
operator representation to prove
equivalences the idea is that here's a
system that we looked at before that was
the Cascade of two simple delay systems
here's a somewhat more complicated
somewhat simpler representation
the point is it's different and if we
compare the operator representations for
the two we see that they are the same
and what I'm about to prove is that when
the operator representations are the
same the systems represent the same
transformations provided they all start
at rest the provided is important
obviously since they have different
delays in them if the delays didn't all
start out at zero the differences in the
delays could propagate into the output
so all of the statements on making our
premise on the idea of initial rest the
other important thing to remember about
operators is that it's a higher level
abstraction we can think about the
operator as composing things but the
things that are composed our whole
signals not samples and here's an
illustration of how to think about that
previous example how do you think about
this transformation 1 - 2 R plus R
squared what happens when you apply that
operator to an input signal X well let's
say that X was our unit sample signal in
order to apply this operator 1 - 2 R
plus R squared all we need to do is
think about each component 1 times X is
X - 2 are applied to X is minus 2r X + R
squared X is just + R squared X so we
start out with X which is a unit sample
- 2 R X means
shifted to the right and multiplied by-
to shift it to the right x minus 2 plus
R squared X being shifted twice to the
right so the result this operator 1
minus 2 R plus R squared applied to X is
just the sum of these things so you can
think about the operator expression it's
just like algebra except that the
elements are signals not samples and as
I alluded previously you can make
powerful statements about the way these
operators work which map isomorphic ly
on to polynomial math so for example
it's easy to prove that if you were to
cascade the 1 minus R operator with R so
apply start with X apply 1 minus R start
with X apply 1 minus R then apply our
that's going to result in the same
signal assuming initial rest as if you
were to flip those operators the way I
can see that is by thinking about signal
flow you remember that I said one of the
features one of the powers of the block
diagram representation is that we can
look at signal flow paths we can use
that as a way of proving things this
system has two signal flow paths the one
that goes straight through that way and
the one that goes down this way and up
that way because of the addition all it
does the the adder just adds the result
of those two flow paths so the first
flow path introduces one delay the
second flow path inverts and puts in two
delays so there are two ways to get from
the input to the output similarly here
there are two ways to get from the input
to the output one of them goes through a
delay and then goes through the adder
the other goes through two delays at a
minus one but that's the same too
signal paths that were in the top way so
that's a way of using the block diagram
to prove a relationship about the
operator what I've just showed is that
the operators obey commutativity so what
I was able to show is that I can commute
these two operators doing a general
proof is slightly more complicated right
I proved it in a special case but the
general case works too
they just like polynomials operators
commute and I indicated why you should
think that's true by thinking about
signal flow paths ah multiplication
distributes over addition I apologize
the diagram in your notes is wrong this
is right I will always post the note so
I get up in the morning I bake coffee
I read the lecture notes and I say oh my
goodness there's a wrong figure in this
particular case one of the staff members
wrote me an email and said hey Freeman
your slide something or other is wrong
he was right so this is the right
diagram so the idea is that if multiple
a multiplication distributes over
addition we should expect that are
applied to 1 minus R would give R minus
R squared and we can again get a feeling
for why that ought to be true by
thinking about the signal flow paths the
two signal flow paths that represe so
the signal flow path that represents
here this says take the 1 minus R
operator and apply it to X then apply R
to the 1 minus R operator result as
opposed to this one says apply the R
operator two acts then apply the R
squared operator to the X and subtract
them if you think about the signal flow
pass through those two systems they're
also the same two signal flow paths and
here's a more complicated example that
shows associativity you can think
through that same idea the reason that
the idea the big important point is
difference equations are a good
representation for discrete-time systems
they're mathematically compact block
diagrams are a good representation but
they have more information they tell you
what is the input what is the output and
what are all the different flow paths
through the system operators kind of
combine the best features of both it's
mathematically concise it tells you
which is the input and which is the
output and you can visualize all the
flow paths by thinking about all the ads
in the operator expression okay to make
sure that everybody is up with me how
many the following systems are
equivalent you have 30 seconds
okay so how many of those are equivalent
more hands were hands not necessarily
more fingers but more hands okay about
75% correct
roughly speaking okay how many signal
flow paths how many distinct signal flow
paths are going through the first system
here's 100 more
three more so here's one here's one
here's one only do is think about all of
the signal flow paths through all of
them make a sum and see how many of them
have the same sum so the path with the
greatest delay through this path is two
times two delay delay two delays with
multiply by four what's the path with
the biggest delay through this one also
straight through also delay of two also
a coefficient of four how about this one
so that's this way so they all have the
same paths with maximum delay the delay
is two in the coefficient is 4 this one
has four possible paths this one only
has three so there's one straight
through this way there's one that has
one fewer delay and there's one that
only has so there's a straight through
one there's a delay of two and there's a
delay of one so let's do the straight
through one this one has a straight
through path no delay coefficient is one
this one has a straight through path
coefficient is one this one has a
straight through path coefficient is 1
so all three systems have the same
maximum delay path they all have the
same minimum delay path we only have one
in the middle
yet this one has two ways to get a delay
of 1 to delay to our or to our since
they're both - are they some so that's
for our this one only has one way that
we can get one delay
and that is to come this way and then go
that way that's for our this one to get
one delay I take the center path that's
for our each path has the same ways to
get through the system with zero delay
one delay in two delays they're
equivalent in the sense that if you
started them with initial rest they
would all generate the same output given
the same input so the answer is three ok
so far I've only worked with systems
that propagate the inputs systematically
through to the outputs we call such
systems feed-forward things are a little
bit different when you have cycles we
call such systems feedback so what I
want to think about now is how do you
think about a system that has a feedback
loop in it the interesting thing that
happens when you have a feedback loop is
that the operator expression no longer
represents a simple sum of input signals
let's look at what happens here so why
is apparently the sum of two things it's
the signal ry which comes around that
way everybody see that so if I think
about labeling this input is X labeling
this output as Y then the the correct
label for this point is don't everybody
shall applause
if this is can label it as the point why
what is the correct label to label this
point all right so the signal y must be
our Y plus X what that says is that if I
applied the 1 minus R operator to Y I
should get X okay that's a fine operator
expression except that it's not a
formulaic operator applied to the input
the operator is applied to the output
okay this is the the the difference here
is the difference between an imperative
system like we talked about block
diagrams when we were thinking about
samples the block diagram tells you what
to do step by step the block diagram
regardless of whether you have feedback
the block diagram always tells you take
X of n add it to Y of n whatever there's
an imperative rule do this we took the
block diagrams and we turn them into
operators and we ended up with something
that is not imperative this is much more
the kind of statement we got when we did
difference equations this is a statement
of truth
it's declarative if you tell me the
signal X it must be true that the
resulting signal Y when operated upon by
1 minus R is X so the idea is that it's
a declaration it's not an imperative
rule does ever going to get that so this
statement up here
told me a rule start with X apply the 1
minus R operator and you will get why
that's an imperative operation do this
this is a declaration if you tell me XY
must be the signal that when operated on
by 1 minus R gives you X but it doesn't
tell me a way to find it it tells me a
truth but it doesn't tell me how to find
that truth so let's go back let's back
up okay we got a representation we like
the representation it's concise it has
many of the features of block diagrams
it doesn't seem to be imperative that's
a problem so let's back up think about
how the same system that ran into a
problem with the operator think about
what must the answer be well the answer
we can figure out by doing step by step
imagine that it starts at rest so the
output starts at 0 and now I just tick
through the samples so when the first
sample comes in X is equal to 1 I'm
thinking about the unit-sample response
we call the Delta function the unit
sample when the unit sample at time N
equals zero comes in at has value of 1
the 1 adds to the initial condition
which is 0 to give me 1 then this output
is 1 so when the clock ticks the input
goes from 1 to 0 but the output of the
delay goes from 0 to 1 so when the clock
ticks I get another one and that
persists does everybody see what's going
on so I initially had a 0 coming out of
the delay the unit-sample made the first
output be 1 but then that one fed back
in to make this be 1 which combined with
the next 0 to give me the same 1 and
that state persisted
what's different is that the output
signal
persists long after the input went away
in fact there is a prescriptive way to
figure out the relationship between the
input and the output it's just that it
takes an infinite number of delays
here's an alternative system that would
generate the same response to a unit
sample signal as was generated by the
simple feedback system it needs to
generate the answer 1 1 1 1 1 11 is just
1
well the the first the output at 0
happens through this path the output at
1 happens through this path the output
at 2 happens through this path 3 etc
there's a separate path for every one of
those separate components of the output
that's how we can think about this
construction the input has a single
nonzero entry the output has an infinite
number we can think about that as
resulting from an infinite number of
paths there's something similar about
the simple feedback system which can be
represented by that operator
representation and the infinite system
which can the infinite feed-forward
system this is a simple feedback system
this is an infinite feed-forward system
there's something the same about those
two in fact they're equivalent in the
sense that if all the delays start out
with ance of initial conditions of 0
they will generate the same response to
all possible input signals those two
signals are equivalent and that's proved
here all you do is you say ok y2 is some
relationship to I to r1 of sorry y2
depends on x2 this way if x2 is the same
as
one I can substitute it but x1 according
to this rule looks like 1 minus ry 1
when you multiply out this mess you get
y1 what I just showed is that if x1 is
equal to x2 then y1 is equal to y2 those
two systems are the same well that's
weird
so there's something the same about that
operator and that operator we write that
this way so here's the feedback system
we think about that as representing the
operator Y over X 1 over 1 minus R so in
order to calculate X cross multiply by X
Y is the operator 1 minus R applied to X
so we want to say Y is the operator what
- are applied to X what is the operator
1 over 1 minus R well if you didn't know
anything but polynomial math you might
have expanded this in a series and in
fact that gives you exactly the right
answer if you were to expand 1 over R in
a series so for example evaluate it
using synthetic division evaluate it
with a Taylor series however you want to
do it
think about R as though it were a number
just like you would if it were a
polynomial expand it just like you would
if it were a polynomial and what you see
is that there's a representation for
this operator 1 over 1 minus R that is
equivalent that's exactly the same is if
I applied the operator 1 plus R plus R
squared plus R cubed
2x those two are equivalent in the sense
that if both systems start out at rest
and if they are both applied to the same
input they both generate the same output
so that gives us that a way of thinking
about operators that have numerators and
denominators so it make sure you're up
to speed
a system is described by the following
operator expression determine the output
of the system when the input is a unit
sample
what's the first thing I should do okay
this is one of those systems that has
the are polynomial in the bottom so it
says that X must be the same signal by
cross-multiplying
X must be the same signal as the 1 plus
2 R operator on the Y ok that's
backwards that's not the way I want to
think about it how do I make that into a
forward statement that tells me what
operator gets applied to X the answer is
that so what do I do x I say you could
cross multiply how do I convert this
into an operator that looks like just a
numerator times X yeah exactly
what I want to do is convert it by
synthetic division Taylor series
whatever method I want to think about
what would 1 over 1 plus 2r look like
what's the reciprocal of 1 plus 2 R that
is 1 minus 2r plus 4 R squared etc so
now I have this which I apply to X which
is a unit sample so now I want to think
about applying this operator to the unit
sample signal but that's easy the first
term just brings out Delta minus 2r
applied the Delta shifts the Delta by 1
gives me Delta of n minus 1 and
multiplies by minus 2 and that whole
mess then just says that my output looks
like this if the input was X which was a
unit sample signal my output has an
infinite number of terms
each one is a delayed version of the
province of the predecessor and the
weights go 1 minus 2 plus 4 minus 8 plus
16 and diverge ok so what we just did
was pretty complicated we just solved a
block diagram but we did it with
polynomial math we did it with math that
you learned in high school that's the
point in fact the point of today is that
any system that's built out of simple
parts delays adders scalars that sort of
thing can be represented by a difference
equation fine that's good
difference equations are wonderful they
can equivalently be represented by an
operator equation the operator equation
has more information in it it knows how
to get from the input to the output it's
imperative it's easy to manipulate you
use the same rules that you use for
polynomials so all in all this is a more
powerful kind of representation and any
system that can be represented by a
difference equation can similarly be
represented by an operator equation
that's why we're focusing on operators
so final question think about fine do
everything backwards now here's a block
diagram find the Associated difference
equation and the idea is to take
advantage of operators in the interest
of time let me just do it if we wanted
to because I'm running out of time so I
could start with the block diagram I
could stay in block diagram domain
presumably that'll work that's hard I
want to do the easy way
so convert it to operators how do you
convert a block diagram to operators
replace the delays by our label all the
signals X becomes X y becomes y
don't have a name for this so I'll call
it e error I don't have a name for this
so I'll call it W who knows
and then I'll Express each of the
relationships imposed by the plus sign
this R or this R by a line of operator
reasoning the plus says that the e
signal is X plus W the R says that the Y
signal is are applied to e this box says
that the W signals are applied to Y I
get three equations in our I just solve
algebraically
none of this different stuff none of
these square brackets with ends in them
I just use algebra so I solve it
algebraically and I get this and that
that translates into a corresponding
difference equation showed here the
point the point is three different
representations difference equations
block diagrams operators operators are
easiest even when I was asked to solve a
problem that has no operators in it it's
easier to cast it into an operator
expression solve it in the operator
domain and then turn it back into a
difference equation starting next week
we will figure out much more powerful
things that we can do with operators
this is just the beginning so with that
let me just summarize that we looked at
three representations and the point of
the labs for the week are going to be to
exercise this to get some experience
with representing signals in Python
you
you